my heads cut off
hey guys how's it goin so I might have
actually forgot how to vlog I didn't
really think it was possible until I sat
down and tried to get my old setup back
with my white wall and I was like
nothing looks right my lighting isn't
correct look what is happening I went
back to my old videos like when is the
last time they actually shot on my
little white wall I got bored and forgot
that that's what I was looking for so I
actually don't really have an answer for
you but I'm sure you guys do have an
answer um what was I even gonna say I
don't know a little sweaty Beijing
unless you've ever actually sat down and
talked to a camera in a room all by
yourself completely alone nobody else
around you to tell you what to do what
your face looks like how stupid you
might look at some point in the frame or
to have that outside perspective of what
you're doing could potentially be better
if there's somebody else telling you
what to do or call a completely
different way because it's been really
interesting because I've been doing a
lot of different shows and working with
like a lot of different people where
they're so my shoulder describes people
involved or if you're like why don't we
just do this there's a lot of people
that are telling you what to do there's
so much that's going on and now to go
back to sitting in my room doing
basically whatever I want it's like
great I can do whatever I want it's also
got a crazy because a lot of people will
say well just do it like you do in your
videos and like well I can't do it like
I'm doing in my videos because I'm
sitting here by myself alone in a room
talking to no one I mean I'm talking to
people obviously I mentally know I'm
talking to you guys
but right now I'm in a completely empty
room talking to a camera which is why
it's really hard for me to ever think
about getting an editor because I start
talking I know exactly what I want and
for me to remember exactly what I said
in a video and explain my thought
process to somebody else I don't know
YouTube I feel like is such a weird
little world where we can all just sit
here hang out and talk a lot of us
youtubers talking to you guys but what I
think a lot of people don't realize is
we do read the comments a lot of time is
spent reading the comments there's a lot
of a lot of love there's a lot of hate
but what's cool is the communities that
are formed around these youtubers and
I'm
kind of coming off of VidCon and being
on all these panels and and talking to
different youtubers and talking to
brands and talking to companies and just
hearing all of these different
perspectives we were just so happy to be
able to have this as a job to be able to
kind of make these videos and do what we
want for you guys
because I don't think you guys realize
what a process it is when you're working
with like these big production companies
or movies or TV shows so I'm sure some
of you guys do because I think that's
the connection with YouTube is we make
what we want for you whereas these
movies and TV shows are actors yes these
actors are real people but they are
playing characters whereas a lot of the
people that you guys watch on YouTube
whether it's a good thing or a bad thing
what you see in their YouTube videos
like that's actually these people like
they are real or a lot of times you meet
somebody and they're so outgoing in
their videos and you meet them in person
and they're just like right before
VidCon Josh funk was made a video it was
like the top things not to say it to a
youtuber when you meet them it was
really funny because he mentioned one
not to say oh you look so much taller
shorter whatever in your videos and you
are in real life
I can't tell you how many times people
have said wow a lot taller no this is me
anyway I don't really know what this
video was made to accomplish I just kind
of sat down I was like I'm just gonna
talk see what happens I have also been
thinking about because I really loved
what I would do like review videos of
things I have actually been buying a
couple of random things off Amazon than
like man I really want to review this I
want to show this to you guys so I got
about doing like every Tuesday so
there's any apps or products that you
guys would like me to try feel free to
leave me a comment below if there's any
other videos that you would like to see
me make or people that you would like to
see me make videos with I really want to
go do another Squatch hunt I've got some
ideas I think I might have something a
lame leg are you oh uh Sasquatch he's
out there I know he's out there doesn't
know where he is that pig I've been
building a lot of LEGO sets lately from
the lego movie I just built an r2d2
which and really pumped about because I
want to show you guys a time-lapse of it
was really fun anyway let me know what
you guys have been up to if you were at
VidCon and I got a chance to meet you oh
you guys are freaking awesome I love you
thank you for all of your fun little
presents let's all cut for this video I
will see you guys in the next one and
hopefully don't forget to hate it I
don't want to say it it's just like how
you're supposed to end your video now
today I think I'm not gonna tell you to
subscribe and like I saw you liked the
video like I'm just gonna shut up this
is not gonna cook right I think I might
have baked my phone inside of this